yeah bro like i'm just so focused even
even
an exclusive even though i'm not even
fighting i like swaziland yeah we had a
feeling
last night
okay can i be honest i'm a little bit
happy about this and really this is no
insult to the guy that you were fighting
yeah yeah but what do you even say
you know his name my dog's name wasabi
no johnny teriyaki johnny teriyaki that
feels racial
are you saying that he couldn't land the
plane of this fight
are you saying that this fight came to a
crash landing
okay listen i know i just didn't know
the guy yeah yeah yeah i know you
obviously
but i don't know this guy and he has my
accent okay so i'm like what what is
going on
where i don't know this american guy
that you're fighting yeah he's not
worthy
but i that there's like a familial thing
like you call your brother and you hate
your brother
he's already living in your shadows it
was like and i'll beat up the guy that
beat you up like this
well i was trying to destroy this boy i
was i'm trying to avenge my brother like
you know
you're powered yeah yeah yeah
i was trying to [ __ ] i'm trying to
avenge my brother
[Laughter]
but no like i was trying to avenge and i
was also just trying to you know [ __ ]
this guy because he's been on my case
for years bro he's been calling me out
constantly over and over and i've been
laughing off like who is this guy you're
not worthy bro you're not on my level
you're side quest i would never even
want to play you bro yeah and then bro i
was like you know what [ __ ] it he's
beating my bro
come to come to england fight me it's my
turn now i'll show you how it's [ __ ]
done and bro like
it's it's annoying because
me and my trainees we knew if we showed
too much
he was going to [ __ ] out bro
we knew he was going to be like oh
actually yo this is kind of long and
we're thinking so at what point do you
think he went this is
this is maybe too much for me the
shirtless pick
maybe maybe it was the transformation or
maybe there was a video of me
you really did transfer
maybe there's a video of me holding a
bar while receiving punches repeatedly
and i'm thinking maybe he saw that and
was like
hmm maybe i need to break my hand
or hey guys i've got a concussion i
can't fight anymore is that what he's
saying so there's room yeah what's the
rumor so
um i think he said he was gonna try and
sue me if i said this incorrectly so
yeah i legally have to say he's got a
doctor's note that says he
has either a concussion or broken hand
i'm not sure which one of the two yeah
but uh he's unable to fight oh wow yeah
as he asked for like a different date
yeah yeah i don't think so yeah do you
want to translate what that means oh he
said you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what he said
legit
he did not want any smoke yeah he got
he
nervous
bro even in the press conference yeah he
had to like um the zoom press conference
i saw the digital press conference he
was not a big fan of the digital yeah
yeah it was it was it was weird the
energy was weird and i'm sure this guy's
a nice kid i i do yeah i'm not familiar
with it i just don't know yeah but uh
and he was like why aren't you fighting
jake and it's like hold on family yeah
like this is your moment like this
you don't even make sense